as we mentioned we reached a half
million positive coven 19 tests in data
released today the true picture however
probably bigger as testing efforts
expand with the emergence of the omicron
variant for the very latest of course
you can go to our website at
eightnewsnow.com
and of course we have much more testing
details as well getting a coronavirus
test is certainly a challenge lines are
long at test size shelves are empty with
at-home kits john langler looks at the
key differences between testing yourself
and getting one from a professional
the bottom line is you need to know do
you have coronavirus and do you need to
stay home doctors say at this stage of
the pandemic you only need one kind of
test to make sure you don't infect
anyone else the line stretched around
the block hundreds waiting to get a
coronavirus test in san francisco
juliano and renata correa don't care
what kind of tests they get they just
need an answer returning to brazil
tomorrow
and we must be tested
before going back
with both rapid and pcr tests scarce
during this post-holiday omicron surge
what do you need which should you get dr
michael mina is chief science officer of
emed the appropriate tool in this
pandemic to answer the question do i
need to isolate
am i infectious and a risk to my
neighbors
is using a rapid antigen test because it
only stays positive as long as you are
infectious rapid tests only detect when
you are infectious and shedding virus
into the air pcr tests are much more
sensitive they detect the virus for
weeks after symptoms stop dr george
rutherford says this is the best use
case for pcr tests if you are older if
you have risk factors
if you think you might be a candidate
for some of the antiviral drugs that are
just coming available now or for
monoclonal antibodies you will
definitely need a pcr
diagnosis for that
because we'll want to understand whether
it's omicron or delta you know all those
kinds of things if you have those rapid
tests and you get false positives
doctors say that is okay if you're
shedding the virus they say it'll be
detecting that you should keep using
those rapid tests to discover when
you're not contagious anymore and then
you can come out of isolation
john langler live local now